this is a graduation season at the
center of controversy a ceremonial
moment here at Edinburgh University in a
mess over a marking boycott caught in
the crossfire students like will from
the US obviously I'm one of several
thousand students around the UK who had
plans to go on to do postgraduate study
but due to the ongoing marketing and
assessment boycott are graduating
without a degree classification
obviously there's been a lot of sort of
stress and frustration around that and
unfortunately has now started to impact
our immigration status as well
added stress for the very many foreign
graduates wanting to continue studying
here they say rules require them to
return home and reapply for a new Visa I
mean I'd have to pay you know upwards of
about a thousand pounds to get flights
back home to Wisconsin I mean I have a
job here I've paid rent on a flat here
as well this is widespread and
unprecedented ceremonies at 145
universities across the UK thrown into
chaos in a road that's been rumbling on
since April thousands of lecturers
refusing to Mark dissertations and
assess coursework as they demand better
pay
the employers need to address the
disruption that we've seen in the
University sector it's been scandalous
we serve notice for the market and
assessment boycott in April we were
talking about it in January they've had
months to resolve this and they've just
failed to do so three two one go
University employers say the current
cash offer is pushing institutions to
their financial limits it seems both
sides will now plot their next move as
the standoff intensifies Conor Gillis
Sky News